I see you some have already seen it but
someone else has yet to plunge into the
World created by the unbridled
imagination of James Cameron in London
in early December the world premiere of
the film Avatar the way of water took
place the main technology that made it
possible to give Avatar's characters
such lifelike Expressions was facial
motion capture huerte digital Studio was
responsible for the special effects in
Avatar especially for the filming of
Avatar 2 they developed a whole new face
capture system that allowed them to
track even the slightest movement down
to the actor's eyes moreover this
technology is even able to cope with
shooting underwater it utilizes markers
on the face which are then recorded
using multiple cameras however due to
the fact that the computer perceived
small air bubbles as markers on their
faces the actors had to dive underwater
without scuba gear and learn to hold
their breath long periods of time to
achieve the perfect results Kate Winslet
even managed to go without air for seven
minutes have you already watched Avatar
the way of water if yes share your
thoughts about it in the comments